did you ever see guys beef out over
chicks most NBA players when you see an
NBA dude ain't like they beat them for
no reason like how did I get out of
control it's probably emotionally over
all the time over a woman did you ever
beef with anybody over a chick no no who
was there somebody who you had like some
like actual like yo I [ __ ] don't like
this guy I'm giving him hard fouls no
because I was [ __ ] this girl or
something like that no no just like you
just didn't like him
I mean sometimes competition can be that
intense so who did you like not [ __ ]
with
like when you were not not personally I
just mean like yo for example I'm a fan
I can't [ __ ] with Pat Beverly because
what he did to Chris Paul you know when
he [ __ ] hit him in the back a couple
years ago because I'm a son's fan oh so
I'm saying like who who did you like who
was like your phone I never really have
no like like if it was you know if it
was you know beef it was just beef
both of we respected each other like I
ain't like I don't [ __ ] no I ain't never
really have that type of
who's this where I'm looking to take
your head off even like even the dudes
from the oh let me see I'm gonna take it
I might take that back you gotta have a
Celtics guy huh
Tony Allen maybe yeah yeah but I'm okay
but okay well okay what I'm saying like
I don't [ __ ] with them it's like more of
a like on a court of course that's what
I mean I don't [ __ ] with them it ain't
like a off the court yeah cause Tony hey
Tony Allen was a [ __ ] yeah but like
Paul Pierce I ain't like Paul Pierce
yeah you know what I mean if he was off
the pick and roll if I could trip him or
something like that to make him let him
fall or
I would do it and he's still Petty as
hell he shows a LeBron every time he
gets a chance somebody who's jealous
yeah yeah yeah Paul Pierce you know he
had to get Ray Allen and uh kg to you
know you know what I mean when that
happened it was that was like the 0809
season they win the first year
did you guys like
because that was I know everybody talks
about LeBron going to Miami but to me
the real first like super team of that
they've been doing that [ __ ] what
they've been doing if I'm talking about
that era when Ray Allen and kg went to
the Celtics and won it they went from
worst team to the best team yeah that's
not what happens when your team get
better and the only one big players that
hate on it
make your team better [ __ ] get
in the gym yeah but I'm saying when when
the Celtics formed that Trio and
obviously that Rondo is a rookie but
like that was great for basketball it
was great like you guys were excited for
it yeah you're not gonna always be one
two yeah look at Larry Bird magic oh you
had Larry Bird uh Mikhail Parish got
magic worthy Kareem right oh those ones
like oh my God they got a super team
well those are super teams for sure what
I'm saying but it was expected